président de l'arcom que je remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
monsieur le Président cette audition est
est bien entendu l'occasion de revenir
comme on le fait chaque année enfin com
comme on le fait chaque année sur votre
rapport d'activité mais c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire un bilan des deux
premières années d'existence de de
l'arcom cette audition est est sur aussi
et surtout l'occasion d'aborder avec
vous les nombreux sujets d'actualité
liés à à l'audiovisuel et et au
numérique
et cette année encore ils sont nombreux
il concerne bien entendu l'audiovisuel
public auquel les membres de la
commission demeurent particulièrement
attachés mais dont l'avenir suscite chez
bon nombre d'entre nous des
interrogations pour ne pas dire des des
inquiétudes ces interrogations
concernent d'abord la la stratégie du
gouvernement à l'égard des sociétés qui
le compose nous avons bien compris que
la réforme du secteur de l'audiovisuel
n'était pas la priorité de de de la
ministre de la Culture pour autant en
décalant de de moi en mois la
présentation des nouveaux comes nous en
venons à nous interroger sur la nature
des des objectifs que l'actionnaire
public entend assigner aux entreprises
d'audiovisuel public pour la période
2024-2028 c'est-à-dire qui commence
maintenant dans 3 semaines ces
inquiétudes portent également sur les
modalités de de financement des sociétés
de l'audiovisuel publ alors que la
poursuite du du financement via une
fraction de TVA est suspendue à une
éventuelle réforme de la loi organique
relative aux finances publiques nous
sommes là encore dans dans l'attente des
précisions du gouvernement sur ses
intentions concernant non pas 2024 comme
pour les com mais l'après 2025 et la
question du du financement je ne vous
demanderai pas monsieur le Président si
vous partagez l'ensemble de de ces
interrogations qui ont malheureusement
conduit le Sénat à rejeté les crédits de
l'audiovisuel public il y a une dizaine
de jours si j'ai bien conscience qu'elle
nous appartient pas de commenter les
choix du gouvernement ou plutôt son
absence de choix je ne peux résister à
l'envie de connaître le sentiment du
régulateur sur le climat d'incertitudes
qu'ils font peser dans ces temps
troublés sur l'audiovisuel public ces
incertitudes sont d'autant plus
regrettables que les acteurs de
l'audiovisuel sont contraints de
poursuivre leur mutation pour répondre à
l'évolution des usages et des
technologies parmi ces mutation il en
est une dont nous avons débattu ici même
en en janvier dernier et qui concernait
la diffusion des service de radio sur le
numérique terrestre à l'occasion de de
cette table ronde vous aviez annoncé
votre intention en présence de
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
premièrement de donner un coup
d'accélérateur au au déploiement du DAB
plus afin de trouver une solution à la
saturation de la bande FM et également
de de préparer un livre blanc sur
l'avenir de la radio à l'image de
l'initiative prise en son temps par le
le régulateur britannique un an après
ces annonces pouvez-vous monsieur le
Président nous informer des des progrès
accomplis en ces deux domaines
l'ensemble des des idateurs vous ont-ils
suivi sur un terrain qu'il semblait
appréhender faute d'accompagnement
financier suffisant de l'État monsieur
le Président je euh je voudrais
compléter ce propos plus introductif par
quelques mots sur la lutte contre le le
piratage à laquelle notre commission
bien entendu l'arcom également est
particulièrement attaché nous avions
organisé en octobre 2022 en présence de
Denis Rapon une table ronde sur la mise
en œuvre de l'article 3 de la loi du 25
octobre 2021 donnant à à l'arcom la
possibilité de de bloquer les les sites
miroirs retransmettant ilégalement les
les événements
sportifs la question problématique du
partage des coûts du blocage avait été
évoqué de même que la nécessité
d'impliquer l'ensemble des intermédiaire
de l'écosystème internet pour rendre la
procédure encore plus efficace ou où en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui et comment
réagir à la à la commercialisation
floridante des boîtiers d'IPT TV
illégaux enfin monsieur le Président
nous sommes intéressés de vous entendre
sur la façon dont les médias français
couvrent le conflit au Moyen-Orient nous
avez organisé il y a quelques jours une
réunion avec les les principaux acteurs
pourriez-vous nous nous préciser si vous
considérez que cette couverture par les
médias français de l'événement
correspond aux attentes ou aux exigences
de l'arc je vais à présent monsieur le
Président vous laisser la parole non
sans avoir préalablement rappelé que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du
Sénat monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs permettez-moi d'abord
d'exprimer mes mes vives félicitations à
toutes celles et tous ceux d'entre vous
qui ont été élus ou ou réélus à
l'occasion du du récent renouvellement
du du Sénat j'ai naturellement une
pensée particulière pour vous monsieur
le Président qui venait d'être reconduit
à à la tête de cette belle commission je
je salue la désignation de Monsieur Vial
également comme rapporteur sur des
sujets que nous aurons en
partage et je suis très heureux que nous
puissions poursuivre nos échanges
auquels j'accorde vous le savez la plus
grande importance l'arcom a eu la chance
depuis 5
de toujours bénéficier à la fois de
l'écoute de votre commission mais
surtout de son de son soutien votre
commission dont l'investissement et
l'expertise reconnu de longue date dans
le domaine audiovisuel sont sont très
précieux pour l'ensemble du du secteur
les
défis auquels sont confrontés les
acteurs tant publics que privés de notre
paysage audiovisuel rendent en effet
plus plus nécessaire que jamais
l'attention des pouvoirs publics dans
leur ensemble aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent la présentation devant votre
commission de notre premier rapport
d'activité en réalité puisque l'arcom a
vu le jour le le 1er janvier
2022 va me permettre d'abord de revenir
sur le bilan de de l'autorité une
autorité très profondément
transformé sous l'impulsion du Parlement
et tout particulièrement sous
l'impulsion du du Sénat tout
particulièrement transformé depuis
depuis 5 ans et qui est pleinement
opérationnel depuis sa sa
création d'évoquer ensuite les les
transformations qui sont à l'œuvre dans
le secteur et leurs implications pour
les opérateurs comme pour les pouvoirs
publics et puis enfin d'aborder devant
vous les grands chantiers de l'arcom
pour l'année à venir qui sera vous le
savez la dernière année de de mon de mon
mandat comme on témoigne ce premier
rapport d'activité l'arcom a été à pied
d'œuvre dès sa création pour remplir ses
différentes missions et achever sa
création quelques chiffres parlent de
même en 2022 le collège s'est réuni 77
fois en collège pliniier a
étudié 1100 dossiers organisé plus de 38
auditions sur les questions du secteur
je vais rappeler quelques échéances de
cette première année
d'exercice l'organisation des élections
présidentielles et législatives qui
naturellement on très fortement mobilisé
nos équipes en charge du du contrôle du
pluralisme en lien étroit avec les
médias audiovisuels mais aussi au titre
de nos compétences avec les plateformes
numériques les partis politiques bien
évidemment et les équipes des différents
candidats nous préparons d'ors et déjà
très activement un scrutin qui aura nous
le savons tous des enjeux majeurs qui
est le scrutin européen de juin de juin
2024 l'année 2022 a été marqué aussi
vous le savez par d'importants projets
de consolidation dans le secteur
audiovisuel qui ont beaucoup mobilisé
les les services de l'autorité je pense
au projet de rapprochement entre TF1 et
M6 qui qui n'a pu aboutir mais je pense
aussi au projet
d'OPA maintenant autorisé du groupe
ivindi sur le groupe gr la
gardire je pense également au processus
de nomination que nous avons dû mener
l'année dernière d'une part à la
présidence de Radio France et d'autre
part à la présidence de France
médiamonde je pense également au
renforcement de notre engagement
européen international d'abord au sein
du réseau européen des régulateurs
l'erga où l'arcom joue un rôle central
mais aussi au sein du réseau francophone
qui rassemble t tous les régulateurs qui
ont notre langue en partage le rérame et
dont nous avons pris la présidence en
2022 jusqu'à la fin de 2024 je pense
enfin vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
Président dans votre propos liminire à à
la lutte contre le piratage avec les les
nouveaux outils dont le Parlement a doté
l'arcom et le Sénat a joué un rôle
décisif en la matière pour la seule
année 2022 c'est plus de 1600 sites
illicites que nous avons bloqué pour
cette première année dans le seul
domaine du sport c'est considérable il y
a incontestablement un avant un après à
la date d'aujourd'hui on est au-delà de
2500 sites donc c'est un effort tout à
fait spectaculaire et à cet égard on
pourrait y revenir nous nous nous
pensons à l'expérience que le cadre
juridique adopté en en 2021 pourrait
probablement être encore renforcé
concernant le piratage culturel cette
fois je pense à la lutte contre le
piratage dans le domaine du du cinéma en
accélérant par quelques ajustements du
du cadre juridique en accélérant les
délais de traitement pour limiter les
phénomènes de de contournement et
étendre la portée du
dispositif au-delà de ces importants
dossiers donc qui ont marqué notre
première année d'activité nous avons
connu d'autres dossiers très
structurants pour une première année
d'exercice nous avons lancé un
observatoire des des podcasts qui est un
un de ces mouvements nouveaux que nous
observons dans dans le SE audioovisuel
et qui va jouer bien sûr un rôle très
important l'accélération du déploiement
de la radio numérique terrestre qui va
couvrir des désormais dans quelques
semaines plus de 60 % de la population
métropolitaine donc on a franchi
maintenant des étapes
décisives je pense également à notre
campagne enfant et écran au titre de nos
activités de protection des des plus
jeunes ou à la conclusion des des
contrats climat qui marquent
l'investissement de notre autorité sur
les sujets de protection de
l'environnement en parallèle il nous a
fallu mener à bien la transformation de
notre institution pour déployer la
création de de l'arcom nombreux
chantiers ont été menés de front notre
collège a été élargi à ne membres ne
membres désignés par C autorités
différentes nous avons adopté un plan
stratégique pour l'autorité qui couvre
la période qui nous mènera jusqu'à
2025 nous avons créé au titre de nos
nouvelles compétences une direction de
la création qui couvre l'ensemble de la
protection du champ de la création de la
fixation des obligations en matière de
financement de la production qui pèse
sur nos acteurs jusqu'à la protection du
droit
d'auteur nous avons organisé la montée
en puissance de notre nouvelle direction
des plateforme en ligne pour mettre en
œuvre les nouvelles compétences qui sont
les nôtres en matière de de régulation
des grands acteurs de de l'Internet nous
avons conformément à la loi organisé la
fusion de nos instances sociales de nos
règlements de gestion et nous avons
regroupé nos locaux pour accueillir
l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs à la
suite de la fusion donc entre l'ancien
CSA et l'ancienne
adopie nous allons d'ailleurs je vous en
informe devoir chercher une nouvelle
implantation puisque notre propriétaire
nous a fait part de son intention
d'effectuer des travaux de
restructuration majeur dans notre site
historique la tour mIRABO et donc nous
allons devoir la la quitter nous
emménagerons dans de nouveaux locaux au
plus tard fin
2024 donc décidément ce ce mandat aura
été particulièrement
riche puisqu'il s'achèvera y compris par
une une implantation nouvelle de de
l'autorité un un mot maintenant si vous
le voulez bien sur les transformations
de notre paysage
audiovisuel qui implique à nos yeux et
et je sais que votre commission l'est et
je l'en remercie qui implique à nos yeux
d'être particulièrement à l'écoute et en
appui de l'ensemble de nos opérateurs
nationaux publics ou privés pour les
accompagner dans leur indispensable
réorientation
stratégique ces transformations on
pourra y revenir sont à mes yeux de de
trois ordres nous observons d'abord vous
le savez tous une profonde
transformation je parlerai même
volontiers d'une révolution des usages
consomme plus les contenus audiovisuels
comme on les consommer dans ma dans ma
jeunesse sur le canapé familial en
regardant l'écran de télévision au
salon cette transformation des usages
s'exprime notamment par la bascule de la
consommation des contenus vers des
consommation de plus en plus à la
demande la durée d'écoute individuelle
qui est l'instr instument de de mesure
pour tous les opérateurs du secteur la
durée d'écoutes individuelle de la
télévision est en diminution
structurelle
elle a diminué de près de 20 % sur les
TR dernières années c'est
impressionnant plus de 50 % des foyers
Français sont aujourd'hui abonnés à au
moins un service de vidéo à la demande
et ils en consomment chaque jour un peu
plus l'âge du téléspectateur l'âge moyen
du téléspectateur de la
télévision traditionnelle est
aujourd'hui pratiquement de 58
ans il est proche de 65 ans pour le
service public et les jeunes les jeunes
générations dont nous faisons tous
partie privilégie naturellement d'autres
vecteurs d'autres
contenus de exemples 2 tiers des moins
de 15 ans 2/ des moins de 15 ans se
rendent chaque jour sur snapchat et les
réseaux les réseaux sociaux constitue le
le premier mode d'accès à
l'information pour 71 % des 15 34
ans c'est une véritable révolution des
usages avec une fracturation des
contenus de la consommation des contenu
qui est très très
frappante cette transformation des
habitudes elle est portée aussi par de
nouveaux équipements
audiovisuels les écrans se
multiplient en moyenne aujourd'hui dans
les foyers français si on inclut ces
petits
outils qui permettent de consommer des
contenus audiovisuels les écrans en
moyenne sont aujourd'hui de 6 par foyer
88 % des foyers français sont maintenant
équipés d'un téléviseur connecté
le téléviseur devient chaque jour un peu
plus vous allez acheter un téléviseur
demain chez un un distributeur dont je
ne citerai pas le nom des marques les
téléviseurs sont de plus en plus des
magasins d'application à l'instar de de
nos téléphones et d'ailleurs c'est là
aussi très frappant l'usage hors
télévision représente déjà un/ers de la
moitié du temps qui consacre les les
plus jeunes de 4 à 34
ans la réalité des usages et et des
modes de réception entraîne une une
reconfiguration du
marché les plateformes de de streaming
vidéo les Netflix Disney plus Amazon
Prime Apple toutes celles qui qui vont
arriver HBO HBO max paramon plus j'en
passe c'est des meilleurs les
plateformes de de streaming vidéo
constittuent pour nos groupes nationaux
une concurrence
croissante qui pèse bien sûr sur
l'acquisition sur les coûts sur la
diffusion de programmes inédit sur
l'accès au
talent notre paysage est également
percuté par le poids croissant des
acteurs du du numérique les fameux gafam
qui sont pour la plupart vous le savez
extra européens et qui absorbent à eux
seuls plus de la moitié des ressources
publicitaires consacré aux médias 2
tiers des recettes de la publicité
numérique en France ont été capté en
2022 par trois opérateurs Google meta
Amazon et bien évidemment tout ça n'est
pas neutre pour nos TF1 nos M6 et tous
nos opérateurs
nationaux dans ce contexte il importe de
préserver le modèle économique et
culturel de nos acteurs nationaux tous
nos groupes audiovisuels sont engagés
d'orénavant dans des réorientations
stratégiques celle-ci les amène à
consentir des investissements
importants technologique ou dans les
contenus et c'est d'ailleurs ces
réorientation stratégique un signe qu'il
faut saluer ici on ne le fait peut-être
pas suffisamment du dynamisme et de la
résilience de nos entreprises je pense
qu'on peut être fier de nos groupes
audiovisuels du dynamisme de leur
dirigeants nos groupes qu' public ou
privé sont aujourd'hui engagés dans un
mouvement pour aller chercher les
publics là où ils sont et notamment les
publics les plus jeunes que j'ai évoqué
toujours que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
en renforçant leur stratégie digitale en
ajustant leur stratégie
éditoriale et en diversifiant leur
modalités de
distribution pour les acteurs privés
cette orientation ce mouvement cette
réorientation stratégique implique bien
sûr de dégager des marges de manœuvre
financière en particulier pour faire
face à la concurrence sur les revenus
publicitaires vous savez que les revenus
pour le secteur de la radio en matière
de publicité sont à la baisse pour la
télévision dira qu'ils sont à peu près
étales à peu près à peu près stables à
un moment où les acteurs doivent
consentir comme je vient d'expliquer des
investissements et c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue face aux métrie
réglementaire qui existe aujourd'hui des
acteurs du numérique qui peuvent capter
tranquillement cette ressource nos
acteurs qui sont soumis à des
contraintes réglementairire important
l'heure est en tout cas probablement
venue d'engager une réflexion sur des
adaptations je pense à la question
récurrente des secteurs interdits de de
publicité je pense à la question qu'on a
souvent évoqué dans cet enceinte des
mentions légales pour la radio qui
contraignent bien évidemment leur
financement pour l'audiovisuel public
monsieur le Président que vous avez
évoqué on sait le rôle fondamental qu'
joue dans l'équilibre du paysage
audiovisuel 30 % des des audiences bien
évidemment un rôle majeur dans dans le
financement de la création un rôle
majeur dans l'information de nos
compatriotes pour l'audiovisuel public
dont l'indépendance et les modalités
d'action doivent être
garanties le gouvernement a fait
connaître trajectoire plurannuelle de de
financement qu'il propose pour la
période
2428 l'arcom a souvent eu l'occasion de
le dire pourra évoquer cela au cours de
l'audition un service public fort c'est
c'est bien sûr un service
public bien financé avec les les
garanties de financement qui s'y
attachent mais c'est aussi un service
public qui sait organiser les synergies
éditoriales et
organisationnels qui sont nécessaires
pour remplir au mieux sa mission au
service des
Français l'arcom l'a l'a régulièrement
dit rejoignant des des préoccupations
que votre commission a a souvent exprimé
la réussite du du rapprochement des
réseaux régionaux de France télévision
et de radio France tout comme le
développement de de France Info
exigeront vraisemblablement en tout cas
c'est notre sentiment
une réponse appropriée en terme de de
gouvernance pour piloter de manière
efficace des projets structurant pour
notre audiovisuel
public tous ces tous ces chantiers sont
au cœur des des priorités de l'arcom
pour l'année à venir qui va être une
année de fortes
échéances ce sera mon dernier point
l'arcom va d'abord poursuivre son
engagement dans la mise en œuvre euh du
règlement européen sur les services
numériques c'est la nouvelle frontière
de la régulation j'en avais fait
personnellement la priorité de de mon
mandat vous vous le savez de faire en
sorte que cette autorité épouse son
temps et puisse s'investir pleinement
dans ce nouveau champ de la
régulation ce règlement européen sur les
services numériques le le fameux DSA
bien connu de du Sénat est entré dans sa
première phase d'application pour les
très grandes plateformes le le 25 août
dernier il sera pleinement applicable
pour l'ensemble des des plateformes
concernées par ce texte le le 17 février
prochain et c'est bien sûr un texte qui
étend et et renouvelle profondément les
mission de l'autorité en matière de
supervision des des plateformes en ligne
il va renforcer très singulièrement
notre positionnement européen auprès de
la Commission européenne puisque la
gouvernance de ce règlement européen est
centré autour de la Commission
européenne en associant des autorités
nationales désignées par chaque pays
membbr de l'Union et le projet de loi
porté par Monsieur barraot déjà voté au
Sénat voté à l'assemblée qui devrait
venir devant une commission mixte
paritaire lui aussi euh au début de
l'année prochaine devrait désigner
l'arcom comme autorité nationale pour
pour la France pour porter ces ces
nouvelles
missions très attendu pour avoir un
Internet Plus Sûr pour porter ses
missions nos équipes sont en cours de de
consolidation
grâce aux moyens qui nous ont été
attribués en loi de finances 2023 et
j'en remercie votre assemblée et le
Parlement dans son ensemble et ceux
qu'il est prévu de nous accorder dans le
projet de loi de finances pour
2024 et je le disais le projet de loi
visant à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique quand il sera adopté donc
devrait désigner l'arcom comme
coordonateur coordinateur national pour
la France de ce texte au côté de laacnil
et de la direction générale de la de la
concurrence et c'est une responsabilité
à laquelle nous nous préparons
activement donc ça c'est un premier très
important chantier pour nous par
ailleurs plusieurs dossiers majeurs en
télévision et en radio figure à notre
agenda pour pour les mois qui viennent
d'abord c'est un moment inédit dans
lequel nous sommes engagés vous savez
que les autorisations de 15 services de
la TNT nationale c'est une première dans
dans l'histoire de notre télévision
arriveront à échéance en 2025 c'est bien
évidemment inutile de le souligner un
dossier à très fort enjeu très fort
enjeu pour le
secteur donc nous sommes dansz déjà
engagé dans ce
processus conformément à la loi nous
avons déjà mené une consultation
publique dont la synthèse sera rendue
publique dans les tous prochains
jours nous menons par ailleurs là aussi
conformément à la loi une étude d'impact
qui est en voie de de finalisation un
très gros travail je pense que votre
commission y trouvera beaucoup
d'informations très très riche très
intéressante sur l'état de la télévision
aujourd'hui en France donc cette étude
sera également rendue publique avant la
fin de cette de cette année le collège
l'adoptera très
prochainement et nous lancerons donc
dans les premières semaines de 2024
début 2024 un appel à candidature pour
l'attribution euh des fréquences qui
arrivent à
échéance j'ajoute en complément de ce de
cette petite présentation que le
gouvernement euh c'est une information
importante pour vous aussi a souhaité
que France Télévision puisse déployer
l'ultra haute définition donc et la
normes supérieure en terme de qualité
d'image de
son puisse déployer voyez l'ultra haute
définition donc l'UHD à l'occasion des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 et
l'arcom chantier également important que
nous venons de mener qui est en cours a
autorisé donc ce déploiement de
l'ultraaute
définition c'est tout tout récemment ces
derniers ces dernières
semaines dans le secteur de la radio que
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
nous poursuivons nos travaux pour
étendre le
DAB+ le livre blanc avance grand pas euh
nous avons bien sûr terminé le cycle
d'audition de l'ensemble des des acteurs
nous sommes dans la phase de de
rédaction et comme je l'avais indiqué
nous rendrons les les conclusions de ce
livre blanc dans le courant du premier
trimestre 2000
2024 enfin un autre dossier d'ampleur
qui touche à notre souveraineté je sais
que vous êtes les uns et les autres très
sensibles et devant nous c'est celui des
des services d'intérêts
généraux qui visent dans ce nouvel
univers des des téléviseurs que j'ai
mentionné rapidement tout à l'heure qui
vise à préserver la bonne
exposition de nos acteurs nationaux et
de leurs programmes dans le nouvel
environnement des des interfaces d'accès
au services audiovisuel là également
nous serons amenés à statuer dans les
toutes prochaines semaines la réflexion
de l'autorité après consultation des
acteurs et et dors et déjà très
avancé sur tous ces sujets les états
généraux de l'information auquel l'arcom
entend contribuer vont être l'occasion
d'une réflexion transversale et
approfondie pour préparer l'avenir d'un
secteur qui est placé au cœur de notre
démocratie au cœur de la vie quotidienne
de nos compatriotes les travaux menés à
l'échon européens notamment en matière
d'intelligence artificielle ou de
liberté des des médias contribuerons
aussi à doter notre continent d'un d'un
cadre juridique adapté aux
transformations du moment car nous le
savons bien d' d'importants défis sont
devant nous j'en citeraai trois
seulement d'abord permettre à nos médias
nationaux de se doter d'un modèle
économique résilient pour assurer leur
mission notamment celle de nous informer
alors que la situation internationale et
les défis que traversent nos sociétés
nécessite plus que jamais une
information pluraliste honnête
indépendante rigoureuse
qui contribue pleinement à la formation
des opinions publiques et au débat
démocratique lutter aussi plus
efficacement contre la désinformation la
haine en ligne les ingérences étrangères
et les actions déstabilisatrice qu'un
bon auteur à qualifier ou à prêter aux
ingénieurs du chaos qui cible parfois
notre pays en tout cas notre continent
et ses valeurs et puis naturellement
protéger la liberté d'expression et le
pluralisme des médias dans un climat
nous l'observons tous de polarisation
extrême du débat et souvent
d'intolérance croissante en tout cas
soyez assurés que l'arcom est pleinement
mobilisé à la place qui est la sienne
sur l'ensemble de ces réflexions
stratégiques je REM vous remercie de
votre attention et me tiens
naturellement à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci monsieur
le Président pour cette présentation
lire très complète déjà de la fois de
l'action 2023 de l'arcom mais mais mais
mais aussi des des enjeux qui sont
devant nous pour l'année à venir sans
plus tarder je cède la parole à mes je
donne la parole à mes collègues en
commençant par notre rapporteur Cédric
Vial merci Messieurs les Présidents
euh merci beaucoup pour pour pour vos
propos qui était assez assez large et et
assez précis moi moi j'aurais juste
trois questions mais qui sont assez
assez ciblé monsieur le Président euh la
première c'est concernant le les crédits
de l'audiovisuel public que nous avons
examiné euh la semaine dernière au au
Sénat euh le le gouvernement envisage
entre 2024 et 2026 de faire bénéficier
le secteur de l'audiovisuel public de
d'environ 200 millions d'euros pour
financer des des projets dans ce qu' ce
qu'il appelle désormais des crédits de
transformation dans le cadre de des
contrats d'objectifs et et de moyens euh
ce ce versement de 200 millions d'euros
pourra être maintenu ou retiré si les
résultats obtenus ne sont pas conformes
aux objectifs de ces projets de
transformation qu'on qu'on ne connaît
pas encore au niveau du du Parlement euh
donc ma question était com comment ça
savez-vous comment seront évalués ces
résultats est-ce que vous allez
participer à l'évaluation des résultats
Quel rôle l'arcom va va jouer dans dans
ce cadre est-ce que l'arcom va formuler
également des des observations enfin
pardon com formule habituellement des
observations en général assez mesurées
sur l'exécution de de ces comes de ces
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens
comment allez va-t-on pouvoir traduire
ces observations en mesurees financière
juste ou proportionné dans le le nouveau
cadre que le gouvernement souhaite poser
euh deuxème question concernant les les
états généraux de de l'information vous
en avez parlé un petit peu sur la fin de
votre intervention l'arcom a lancé une
étude sur l'avenir du marché
publicitaire ce marché se déplace
progressivement vers le numérique enfin
progressivement c'est un euphémisme
notamment vers les moteurs de recherche
et les réseaux sociaux au détriment des
des médias et du véritable travail
journalistique est-ce que cette étude de
l'arcom pourrait aboutir d'après vous
sur des recommandations d'ordre
législatif ou réglementair pour définir
de nouveaux équilibres sur les marchés
publicitaires alors que les acteurs
rentrants ne sont pas soumis vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure aux mêmes contraintes
que le les acteurs du secteur historique
et enfin ma dernière question quel est
votre regard sur la bataille
informationnelle qui se joue dans le
domaine de l'audiovisuel comme dans
celui du numérique alors que le contexte
international est aujourd'hui
extrêmement tendu le risque d'ingérence
étrangère est particulièrement élevé
dans la perspective des Jeux Olympiques
les médias sont également des cibles
potentielles de cyberattaque les fausses
informations et les narratifs
alternatifs éventuellement propagés par
des puisances étrangères semblent de
moins en moins maîtrisable comment
pensez-vous pouvoir traiter cette
question et disposez-vous de moyens
suffisants je n'ai pas cité
l'intelligence artificielle mais ça
pourrait également être une une
dominante de de cette dernière question
voilà je vous remercie monsieur le
Président je vais vous laissez répondre
aux questions du
rapporteur merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour ces trois trois questions sur
l'audiovisuel
publ même si le reprendre votre
expression même si l'autor été le fait
de façon mesurée c'est sa nature je
dirais
euh il formule ses observations
néanmoins avec conviction euh et dans
les avis que nous avons pu rendre sur
l'exécution des contrats d'objectif et
moyen du du service public ou sur le
respect du du cahier des charges des
entreprises du service public nous avons
à plusieurs reprises souligné des point
qui nous semble important pour
l'échéance qui est devant nous celle des
des contrats d'objectif en cours de
d'élaboration et et et nous sommes comme
comme vous encore dans un climat
d'incertitude puisque nous n'avons pas
eu communication l'arcom rendra en temps
et heure son son avis sur ces projets
nous avons toujours souligné des points
qui nous paraissent essentiels il y a il
y a aujourd'hui comme pour les acteurs
privés des enjeux décisifs pour pour le
service public la question du
rajunissement de ces publics un enjeu
majeur je citaé l'âge moyen du
téléspectateur sur le service public on
peut pas se satisfaire qu'un service
public qui doit s'adresser à tous les
Français ne touche pas davantage les les
jeunes publics l'offre de proximité on
le voit bien au moment où les acteurs
privés déploient des initiatives pour
être plus présents dans les territoires
l'offre de service public doit à
l'évidence être rénovée modernisé
concentré pour être plus plus efficace
la stratégie numérique des groupes du
service public doit bien évidemment être
rassemblé unifié je rappelle que notre
pays est singulier c'est le seul pays
pratiquement en Europe où le service
public soit éclaté dans tous les pays
européens le service public est
rassemblé en Angleterre en
Italie dans pratiquement tous les pays
de tous les pays de l'Union et je pense
que cette
idée du du rassemblement des forces qui
est porté du côté du secteur privé
doit être considéré avec attention pour
pour le service public aussi et de ce
point de vue-là l'arcom fait deux
observations sur sur le financement nous
sommes très attachés à un financement
dédié au service public que nous
considérons comme une condition de son
indépendance
et du financement des nombreuses
missions particulières qui lui qui lui
incomb actuellement il y a une solution
transitoire qui a été mise en œuvre qui
est celle d'un d'un prélèvement d'une
fraction de TVA pour se substituer à
l'ancienne contribution à l'audiovisuel
public sa pas quelles sont les les
modalités que le gouvernement retiendra
dans dans ces propositions pour 2025
mais cette option la pérénisation de
cette option nous paraîtrait une
solution de nature à répondre à ce
besoin de garantie d'indépendance et la
deuxième observation je l'ai évoqué à
propos deux dossiers qui sont à mes yeux
emblématiques France Info et le
rapprochement de de France 3 France
Bleue c'est des enjeux très importants
France 3 France Bleue schématiquement
c'est un/ers des effectifs de chacune
des entreprises c'est c'est de des
résseau des réseaux très significatifs
le le succès de ces convergences le
succès de ces
rapprochements ne pourra pas être laissé
à la seule bonne volonté des partis il
faut arriver à trouver une forme de
gouvernance qui permettent de porter ces
projets il faut un pilote dans l'avion
pour employer une une formule en tout
cas pour piloter C ces deux projets très
très
structurants de ce point de vue-là le
gouvernement envisage donc de dans dans
son financement de déployer une une
dotation spécifique pour accompagner les
projets de transformation vous l'avez
évoqué cette dotation de de 200 millions
d'euros qui serait libéré par tranche en
fonction de de de la mesure des des
résultats atteints euh au regard
d'objectif qui serait fixés dans le
contrat une mission a été confiée à
l'Inspection Générale des Finances qui
est en cours de travail avec les
entreprises de l'audiovisuel et dont les
conclusions seront semble-t-il connues
au début de l'année prochaine qui
permettrait d'identifier précisément euh
les objectifs d'une part les indicateurs
de mesures euh qui permettraiit
d'apprécier année après année l'atteinte
de ces de ces résultats l' est bien
évidemment tout à fait prêt dans les
avis annuels qu'elle rend sur
l'exécution des contrats d'objectif a
jouer son rôle dans l'examen de ces
indicateurs annuels qui conditionneraiit
la la
libération de de la tranche annuelle de
de soutien
euh mais elle soulignera dans son avis
qu'il est essentiel que les indicateurs
permettent effectivement de mesurer les
progrès réalisés chaque année donc ça
suppose d'avoir vraiment des indicateurs
précis des objectifs attendus chaque
année dans ces projets de de
rapprochement en
particulier sur les états généraux de de
l'information l'arcom bien évidment va
va y participer je serai auditionné
moi-même par le comité de pilotage des
des États généraux début de début de
l'année
prochaine au titre de notre contribution
nous avons lancé de deux études
importantes l'une sur les Français
l'information qui je crois sera sera
très riche pour pour nous tous même si
il y a desj a eu des des des travaux
menés en la matière mais c'estêre une
étude très très complète avec un panel
un panel extrêmement large et qui
permettra d'avoir un regard très très
précis très complet sur la façon dont
don dont les Français expriment leurs
attentes en matière de d'information et
puis cette étude que vous avez évoqué
qui sera prête je pense dans le courant
du mois de janvier ou milieu du mois de
janvier j'espère sur la publicité c'est
une étude qu'on mène conjointement avec
les les services du du ministère de la
Culture qui est aussi intéressé et ça
devrait permettre on en connaît
déjà les pr les prés résultats
d'objectiver d'objectiver les tendances
de fond de ce marché et les enjeux qui
ont résulte pour chacune des familles de
de médias et l'idée c'est bien
évidemment de venir nourrir la réflexion
et des
propositions pour soutenir le modèle
économique de nos médias je pense qui
est au cœur des états généraux de
l'information c'est
comment assure-t-on le modèle économique
de l'ensemble de nos médias pour les
années qui viennent en matière de presse
écrite de radio de de
télévision probablement qu'il y a des
points au regard des des asymétries
entre les acteurs du numérique et les
acteurs traditionnels où il faudra faire
évoluer la la réglementation en tout cas
l'objet de cette étude c'est de donner
une base commune de réflexion objective
un constat objectif pour que chacun
puisse ensuite prendre les
recommandations les propositions et les
décisions qui qui
s'imposent la bataille informationnelle
et c'est bien évidemment un enjeu
central aujourd'hui les ingérances
étrangères je pense qu'elles exigent
elles vont exiger en tout cas pour
l'année 2024 à mon
sens une vigilance
extrême les élections européennes on le
voit bien dans le contexte géopolitique
du continent mais pas
seulement peuvent inciter certains
acteurs à vouloir peser sur le
déroulement de ce scrutin au sein des
différents pays de de l'Union donc la
France c'est doté vous le savez d'un
service à compétenence nationale viginum
qui est placé auprès du secrétaire
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale qui est destiné à à lutter
précisément contre les ingérences
étrangères l'arcom au titre de ses
compétences en matière de lutte contre
la manipulation de l'information et au
titre des relations étroites qu'elle
entretient avec les plateformes
numériques du fait de ses compétences
est associé à la gouvernance de de
viginum j'ai l'occasion de d'échanger
avec le secrétaire général de de la
défense il y a pas très longtemps et
donc on se prépare d'ors et déjà à
l'organisation de de ce
scrutin je voudrais souligner qu'en
qu'en 2022 pour le scrutin président
et pour les législatives nous avions
réuni l'ensemble des plateformes
numériques dès le mois de janvier et
nous avons échangé avec
ell grosso modo tous les 15 jours
pendant toute la phase électorale et que
sur tous ces sujets de de manipulation
d'information nous avons eu une
collaboration très positive de leur part
toutes ces plateformes maintenant sont
sont rompu à ces processus électoraux
avec l'expérience des scrutins
américains d'élection générales qui se
sont déroulé dans toute une série de de
de pays elle mettent en place au moment
des élections des des cellules
spécifiques pour suivre ces ces sujetsl
et donc on on veillera bien évidemment à
être très attentif au sujet de à ces
sujets de de manipulation de de
l'information de de façon plus générale
au regard de votre question je l'évoqué
dans mon dans mon propos
introductif je pense qu'il est très
important d'accompagner nos acteurs
traditionnels et et de veiller à la
soutenabilité de leur modèle financier
parce que
l'information coûte cher une information
professionnelle avec des rédactions qui
vérifient l'information qui la
contrôle c'est c'est un coût très
important et donc si on veut assurer au
français une information indépendante
pluralistes rigoureuse honnête ça
suppose d'avoir des médias pluralistes
des médias correctement financés et je
crois qu'on est dans une période où il
faut être très attentif précisément à
leur modèle économique ça vaut pour pour
le service public je l'ai dit c'est pour
ça que ces conditions de financement
sont importantes mais ça vaut pour nos
pour nos médias privés vous m'aveiez
interrogé monsieur le Président sur le
conflit du Proche Orient j'ai eu
l'occasion de réunir l'ensemble des des
rédactions des médias publics et et
privés de notre de notre pays euh qui
nous ont fait part des des difficultés
qu'il rencontrait dans la couverture de
ces de ces
événements difficulté dans l'accès à
l'information bien évidemment c'est
qu'il y a des territoires sur lesquels
la présence des correspondants est un
vrai sujet la difficulté de de
vérification du coup des informations
pour qu'elle puisse être délivrée avec
sûreté avec avec
certitude on a observé et le régulateur
a été amené et sera encore amené à à
intervenir sur quelques médias on a pu
observer ici ou là quelques dérapages
euh mais le vrai sujet là aussi c'est
quand même sur la sphère numérique que
qu'elle se pose les vrais dérapages
qu'on a observé c'est bien sur les
réseaux sociaux et vous savez qu'au
titre du Règlement sur les service
numérique la Commission européenne
Thierry Breton le commissaire européen
s'est exprimé à plusieurs reprises
là-dessus la Commission européenne a
engagé des premières actions au titre du
règlement européen à l'égard notamment
de de X successeur de de
Twitter pour une éventuelle
nonconformité au règlement du DSA au
regard de la nature de certains contenus
qu'on a qu'on a pu circuler de façon
viralisée sur ces sur ces plateformes
voà j'espère avoir répondu à vos
questions monsieur le rapporteur alors
je vais prendre l'ensemble de de vos
questions en commençant par Max
BR merci Monsieur président monsieur le
Président d'abord à mon tour de vous
remercier de votre tableau très précis
très didactique euh ce ce que vous avez
déjà dans le passé appelé la la triple
révolution qui menace la télévision
traditionnel il y a un an lors de vos
vœux de l'installation de l'arcom et
depuis de manière récurrente vous
rappelez qu'une des ambitions de l'arcom
est de favoriser le dynamisme de nos
acteurs nationaux face à la concurrence
mondiale et vous venez encore de le
rappeler au-delà d'éditeurs comme TF1 ou
M6 il s'agit de défendre l'ensemble de
l'écosystème audiovisuel français au
sein duquel les distributeurs comme les
fournisseurs d'accès à Internet ou canal
plus jouent un rôle central or si on
perçoisement quoi soutenir la
transformation des producteurs des
chaînes de télévision et de
l'audiovisuel publici est essentiel tant
il concourt à notre souveraineté
économique et culturelle il demeure je
crois un angle mort qui restreint notre
compréhension de l'écosystème je
parleris du rôle des distributeurs de
services de télévision déclarés auprès
de l'arcom dans la valorisation et la
diffusion de programmes originaux face
aux télévisions connecté eux aussi sont
déstabilisés
par ces nouveaux acteurs et subissent de
plein fouet ces mutations pourtant à
travers leur partenariat avec les
éditeurs ces opérateurs protègent
l'accès la visibilité des chaînes
françaises face à la concurrence
internationale si nous souhaitons que le
public continue à bénéficier d'une offre
diversifiée les distri les distributeurs
nationaux doivent être favorisés au même
titre que les services de la TNT c'est
un enjeu de souveraineté culturelle
conformément à la mission qui lui a été
confié par la loi l'arcom travaille
actuellement vous l'avez dit sur la mise
àavant des services dit d'intérêt
général le législateur ayant limité ses
services aux seuls acteurs du service
public dans votre réflexion qui semble
sur le point d'aboutir avez-vous pris en
compte le rôle central des distributeurs
nationaux dans l'accessibilité au du
public au service français face à la
concurrence des opérateurs étrangers qui
n'y seront pas soumis une régulation
supplémentaire ne risque-t-elle pas
d'affaiblir uneou nouvelle fois les
distributeurs nationaux et donc de
porter atteinte à notre souveraineté
culturelle ne faudil pas que la France
fasse évoluer la législation pour
imposer à des services identiques les
mêmes obligations que celles qui income
au distributeurs nationaux ne
faudrait-il pas enfin le cas échéant
pousser dans le sang d'une évolution du
droit communautaire pour reconnaître les
acteurs connectés comme des
distributeurs à partentière je vous
remercie Sylvie Robert
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président vous
l'avez dit en 2024 l'arcom va donc
lancer un appel à candidature pour le
renouvellement de 15 fréquences donc
lesquelles arriveront à échéance 2025
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
marqué par la très forte concurrence
entre les groupes audiovisuels par les
stratégies de consolidation mais aussi
par l'intérêt croissant des plateformes
numériques pour le canal TV cette
procédure d'autorisation revête de mon
point de vue un enjeu
considérable j'ajouterais vous l'avez
aussi souligné que cette procédure ne
s'est jamais déroul dans un climat
politique et informationnel ça je le je
le pense vraiment aussi polarisé aussi
détérioré peut-être même source de
tension de polémique pour le dire
simplement votre mission s'annonce très
délicate alors en matière d'information
nous avons constaté vous l'avez fait à
plusieurs reprises monsieur le Président
de graves et répétés manquement au
pluralisme et de manière générale aux
obligations déontologique qui figurent
dans les conventions que vous signez
avec les chaînes autorisées à
diffuser je cite un alinéa que j'ai pris
dans une convention assez intéressante
qui cite bien sûr le respect des
différentes sensibilités politiques
culturelles et religieuses du publ qui
demande de promouvoir les valeurs
d'intégration et de solidarité qui sont
celles de la République et à lutter
contre les discriminations et cetera
dans certains clans emblématiques alors
que la convention précise que le service
est consacré à l'information nous avons
constaté une l glissade vers la
diffusion d'opinion toujours identique
allant à l'encontre du principe de
pluralisme et du traitement
déontologique de
l'information Monsieur le Président
analysez-vous ainsi aussi cette tendance
et dans le casre de la future procédure
de renouvellement des fréquences
envisagez-vous de muscler les
conventions signées avec les chaînes
d'information afin d'éviter qu'ell ne se
transforme en médias
d'opinion deè question qui Pora sur le
DAP plus
pardon laissez finir je continue je vous
remercie qui ma dernière question va
porter sur le DAB plus et notamment sur
son déploiement équilibré dans les
territoires je cite un exemple en
Bretagne seul 25 radios associatifs sur
32 vont basculer en Daap
plus autrement dit les les auditeurs
bretons et notamment ceux des zones
rurales vont être confronté à une
diminution de l'offre est-ce que la
stratégie de l'arcom va être vraiment
pour essayer de déployer de façon
équilibrée le DAB dans les territoires
même de créer puisque j'ai la demande
aussi de de d'obtention de fréquence
pour une radio notamment en langue
régionale et est-ce que il est prévu de
renforcer l'accompagnement des radios
associatif qui diffuse encore en FM et
en daappus pour les pour prendre en
compte bien sûr les coûts induits par
cette double diffusion et enfin une
observation vous avez cité mais pas
complètement je voudrais avoir votre
avis on observe un mement croisé où les
télés vous l'avez dit ce plateformise
alors c'est pas un terme très mais où
les plateformes se télévisent je sais
pas comment dire et à la fois sur le
plan des contenus mais aussi sur la
forme avec la pub je trouve que c'est
une tendance qui est quand même assez
forte et qui va probablement être aussi
pour vous peut-être un laboratoire
d'observation o il y aura des
conséquences pour l'arcom donc j'avais
envie aussi d'avoir votre avis sur cette
tendance merci
monsieur qui je le rappelle préside
également la la Commission spéciale sur
le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
l'espace numérique merci Monsieur le le
président tout d'abord je voudrais poser
la question suivante à rocovili MS c'est
que devant la démultiplication des
missions qui sont conférées à l'arcom
laquelle a fusionné CSA ADOPI déjà une
première étape mais en application du
fameux RSN et depuis la loi il on lutter
contre la manipulation de la formation
vos missions sont démultiplié jugez-vous
à l'ONE des crédits qui ont été votés
pour cette année voit de finance 2024
que vous disposez des moyens suffisants
et aussi des compétences et qu'il est
facile de recruter aujourd'hui les
compétences dont vous avez besoin ça
c'est ma première question ma deuxème
question complète celle de notre
rapporteur Cédric Vial en tout cas dans
son prolongement vous avez monsieur le
président dit que la meilleure façon
d'armer somm toute notre audiovisuel
face à la désinformation c'est lui
garantir suffisamment de moyens pour
pouvoir euh travailler dans le cadre de
la présidence française d' l'Union
européenne euh avait été tenu et vous y
aviez participé des États généraux avec
l'ensemble des audiovisuels publics
européens et et je crois savoir qu'elle
la tribune les uns et les autres don
vous-même s'étaz exprimer justement sur
la nécessaire euh non budgétisation
c'est-à-dire l'indépendance des médias à
travers une ressource affectée et donc
bien une dotation publique et non une
dotation d'État pouvez-vous préciser
votre propos de de de de l'époque qui
garantit l'autonomie de de l'audiovisuel
publi sur les écrans vous avez aussi
fait état de la la préservation de la
bonne exposition des écrans je sais que
vous meniez va emmener avec Carole
Bienaimé B qui a quitté le CSA tout un
travail sur l'exposition des très jeunes
aux écrans vous savez qu'un un texte de
loi a été voté à unanimité à partir de
notre commission quelques années visant
à encadrer l'exposition des tout petits
des moins de 3 ans un texte similire
d'ailleurs a été voté à l'initiative de
la députée Caroline janvier à
l'Assemblée nationale mais ils ne se
sont pas encore pour l'instant retrouvés
pouvez-vous nous dire ce que vous
concrètement vous vous faites et les
problèmes que vous rencontrez par
rapport à la protection de ces de ces
tout petits en attente d'une législation
euh s'agissant de l'application du DSA
sur lequel nous travaillons en effet au
sein de la commission spéci sécurisé
régulieresace numérique dont plusieurs
membres de cette commission sont
également membres nous sommes préoccupés
par plusieurs points le texte est
d'ailleurs dans la navette en attend des
notifications de de Bruxelles euh depuis
lors on a forcément été très attentif à
l'arrêt de la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne du 9 novembre qui semble
gravement mettre en cause toute
possibilité d'imposer au niveau national
des obligations aux plateformes euh or
l'arcom à travers les textes déjà
adoptés j'ai cité la loi visant à lutter
contre la manipulation de l'information
mais je vrais citer la loi majorité
numérique ou d'autres texes à venir
précisément comme le
sren tout ça c'est au cœur de la
régulation nationale quelle est votre
analyse et surtout selon vous les
conséquences pour pour votre autorité de
de de régulation euh un sujet également
le fait que l'Assemblée nationale a
choisi pour ce projet de loi sren de
revenir au texte initial sur les
articles 1 et 2 qui instaur un contrôle
de l'accès au sititees pornographique
donc cela se traduit par une absence de
coordination entre le contrôle du
respect du référentiel établi par
l'arcom par vos soins donc à l'article
1er et les sanctions pénales à l'article
2 pardonnez-moi chers collègues de ces
questions un peu techniques mais elles
sont essentielles que pensez-vous de
cette évolution et y voyez-vous un
risque de fragilisation du dispositif
avenir voilà et enfin comment
concevez-vous votre rôle de coordinateur
des services numériques en application
du DSN qui est prévu à l'article 25 du
10 projet de loi je vous remercie
Monique de
Marco je vous remercie certaines
questions ont été poser je vais
compléter monsieur le Président voilà
cette semaine j'ai lu un rapport donc de
la Fédération internationale des
industries
phonographique qui soulligne le fait que
il y a 27 % de personnes interrogés qui
utilise les méthodes illégales ou sans
licence pour écouter auou télécharger de
la musique l'arcom ne doit-il pas
renforcer sa surveillance quelle
pourrait être son rôle justement parce
que cette recrud d'esence a l'air de de
s'imposer ensuite j'ai une question au
point de vue national comment
anticipez-vous l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle au sein des
rédactions audiovisuell par exemple et
une deuxième question qui rejoint un
petit peu une interrogations sur le plan
européen comment envisagez-vous votre
nomination certaine pour
l'herga comme régulateur sur la liberté
de la presse en France sachant que cela
semble être en contradiction avec son
histoire
pierreouas merci Monsieur le le
président merci pour la la qualité de de
votre propos et ce et ce bilan tout à
fait intéressant comme j'arrive en fin
de de questionnement moi j'aimerais
reprendre
la question de l'intelligence
artificielle qui me semble tout à fait
fondamentale le Parlement européen a
défini quelques grands objectifs pour
une future législation dont on connaît
pas aujourd'hui exactement quel pourrait
être le le périmètre précis il est à
noter que le gouvernement français de
façon assez singulière s'est opposé à
une législation dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle un ancien
ministre monsieur Cédrico ayant même m
développer une campagne très active pour
expliquer que merci pour expliquer que
ça serait contraire au aux intérêts de
la France que de réglementer
l'intelligence
artificienne pourtant vous avez déjà une
action qui est très forte sur les les
algorithmes et la commission d'enquête
du
Sénat a montré combien s'agissant du cas
particulier de TikTok ces algorithmes
pouvaient être toxiques et on imagine
bien que si vous doublez ces algorithmes
avec de l'intelligence artificielle on
peut arriver à des choses où il y a plus
de contrôle humain dans la production de
ce qui est essentiel aujourd'hui pour
l'information c'est-à-dire l'image et
dans un conflit comme ceux que nous
vivons aujourd'hui on voit très bien ce
que pourrait
être l'impact d'image construite par
l'intelligence artificielle donc c'est
sur ce point que j'aimerais vous vous
interroger pour voir quel est votre
niveau de de réflexion et après demande
très technique est-ce que vous pourriez
si si si si vous le connaissez nous
préciser de façon plus précise le
calendrier exact du renouvellement des
chaînes de de la TNT merci monsieur le
Président Annique
billon merci monsieur le Président merci
à vous monsieur le Président également
euh je voudrais revenir sur les travaux
de la délégation au droits des femmes
sur la pornographie et puis comme j'ai à
côté de moi une des rapporteurs je pense
qu'elle reviendra aussi sur le sujet on
le sait 2 tiers des enfants de moins de
12 ans ont accès à des images
pornographique 1/ers 1/ers des enfants
de moins de 12 ans et 2/3 des enfants de
moins de 15 ans la pornographie c'est
l'exploitation commerciale de la
représentation explicite et filmé de
pratiqu sexuelles non simulées alors je
voudrais dans ce cadre euh revenir sur
eu des contenus les contenus frenchy
Shore et qui euh qui finalement tombent
largement sous sous cette définition je
sais que le président Gérard Larcher et
le président Lafond ont été assez
sensibilisé à ce sujet et je
peut-être vous poser quelques questions
à ce sujet
euh on a eu avec le projet de douan
pardon je suis un peu malade enrumé
excusez-moi ça raisonne dans le nez euh
avec le projet de loi numérique et à
l'instant Catherine main de sayli est
revenue dessus nous avons vu les
difficultés à appliquer la loi pour
interdire l'accès des mineurs à ces
contenus alors pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas trop le contenu des de
cette cette téléréalité qui a été lancée
en France en de en novembre 2023 je
voudrais dire que ces contenus frenchy
Shore ils sont accessibles sur les
plateformes MTV et Paramount c'est des
contenus avec un accès payant mais en
réalité ils sont relayés largement sur
les réseaux sociaux et donc accessiblebl
à tout tous globalement il y a un
message qui est de prévention au départ
mais finalement comme ils sont relayés
sur les réseaux sociaux ils sont
accessibles à tous les mineurs très
facilement euh il est question de
d'agression sexuelle puisqu'il y a
défaut de consentement dans certains
contenus il est question d'actes sexuel
et donc la ministre de la Culture a
estimé que l'émission était finalement
avec des contenus pornographiques et
qu'elle souhaitait des mesures euh de la
part de l'arcom euh donc la ministre de
la Culture vous a finalement demandé de
réguler cette téléréalité et euh à cette
à cette demande je vous avez répondu
l'arcom a répondu semble-t-il que vous
n'étiez pas compétent puisque les
plateformes qui hébergent euh ces sites
euh ne sont pas installés en ces
émissions pardon ne sont pas installées
en France euh c'est normalement au
régulateur du pays d'implantation euh
qui doit agir qui est compétent pour
agir l'arcom ne peut intervenir sur les
contenus des services de streaming
internationaux donc dans le cas de MTV
France et paramon plus l'éditeur du
premier ét en basé à Prague et le second
à Berlin seuls les régulateurs tchqus ou
Allemands peuvent intervenir c'est donc
ce que vous euh portez comme réponse
auprès de la ministre de la Culture euh
donc vous alertez d'ailleurs euh vos
homologues sur les vives réactions qui
ont suscité ces ces contenus à la fois
dans l'Hexagone et vous pointez des
interrogations quant au au aux objectifs
d'une part du respect de la protection
de la dignité humaine et d'autre part de
la protection des mineurs qui évidemment
n'est pas garantie dans ce cas-là donc
euh d'un côté nous avons la ministre de
la Culture qui dit que vous êtes
compétent de l'autre côté l'arcom dit
que vous n'êtes pas compétent donc moi
je voudrais juste vous poser une
question simple monsieur le Président
que faut-il pour que vous soyez
compétent pour pouvoir réguler ses
contenus je vous remercie merci
Mariepierre
Monier merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues alors d'abord je
m'associe aux questions donc du coup ça
sera qu'une remarque sur les moyens dont
vous allez disposer parce que vous avez
bien égriné tout un nombre de missions
supplémentaires que vous avez exercé
vous avez parlé de 200 millions qui
allaient vous être alloué par tranche
mais vous avez aussi spécifié que il y
avait des objectifs bien précis et qu'il
faudrait bien contrôler que les
objectifs sont atteints donc je je
rejoins au fond la question de de mes
collègues précédemment je m'associe à
celle de d'anque également parce que je
suis membre de la délégation au droits
des femmes et les remarques qu'elle a pu
vous faire font suite à un rapport qui
qui a eu un grand retentissement et
surtout qui a pointé de de grandes
problématiques justement je crois que
par rapport à ce que vous avez précisé
tout à l'heure sur le projet de loi
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
euh la version issue de l'Assemblée
nationale prévoit que l'arcom aura 2
mois
pour élaborer un référentiel général
fixant les exigences techniques
auxquelles devront se confronter les
systèmes de vérification d'âge des sites
pornographiques prévu par le texte moi
j'aimerais que vous reveniez sur ce
délai me
disiez que vous puissiez me dire si
vraiment vous pensez que ce c est
suffisant
merci monsieur le Président de l'arcom
je voudrais vous interroger donc
surexprimentation qui actuellement mené
sur les sites pornographiques est censé
d'ailleurs suivre l'une des
recommandations des de notre rapport
publié maintenant il y a 18 mois pourn
l'enfer du de coror qu' rédigé notamment
par ma collègue et voisine et malade
Annique
billon en mars dernier donc un avis de
LARCOM je le rappelle avait défin le
principe du double anonymaat je cite
comme le système le plus robuste non
seulement pour résoudre une bonne une
fois pour toute la question de la
vérification d'âge sur les sites porno
mais éventuellement à l'avenir pour
effectuer d'autres vérifications d'âge
nous sommes tous ici en tout cas
conscient que ce système opérant de
vérification les avancées législatives
en tout cas voté demeure malheureusement
veine et donc sans véritable effet dans
la pratique lors du même mois de mars le
ministre Barot avait d'ailleurs indiqué
au députés de la délégation au droits
des enfants que le site d'orsell devait
réaliser une telle expérimentation afin
évidemment de protéger nos mineurs de
ces contenus inappropriés de fait je
souhaiterais donc savoir si vous aviez
des éléments relatif au résultats de ces
premières expérimentations à nos
communiqués parce que il y a vraiment
aucune information là-dessus et je
voulais aussi vous interroger sur celle
menée récemment par Docapost qui est une
filiale numérique du groupe la poost qui
vient juste d'annoncer he je crois que c
en date du 10 novembre une
expérimentation d'une solution pour
garantir enfin véritablement l'anonymat
des internautes et protéger les mineurs
je vous
remercie Pierre-Antoine levvi
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président d'arcom pour pour
le le le détail de vos propos et sur le
rapport d'information alors plusieurs
questions que je voulais poser ont été
ont été posées notamment par ma collègue
Annique billon donc je voulais savoir
effectivement sur les émissions
controversi comme frenchy sort quelles
sont les limites les compétences de
l'arcom dans la régulation de ce type de
contenu est-ce que pouvezous également
nous détailler comment l'arcom équilibre
la liberté d'expression et la nécessité
de modérer des contenus potentiellement
offensant ou discriminatoire je pense au
sketch de Guillaume Meuris sur Radio
France sur lequel vous avez fait des des
remarques bien évidemment et ensuite je
une question concernant la l'annonce par
TF1 de la du lancement le 8 janvier de
la matinale matinale qui va venir
concurrencer différentes matinales qui
existent sur une offre qui est déjà
largement qui est très importante je
voulais savoir quand vous avez renouvelé
la licence de TF1 il y a quelques mois
est-ce que vous étiez au courant ou
est-ce que vous avez été informé de
cette annonce et quel est votre avis en
tant que régulateur sur le lancement de
cette
matinale
prochainement Laurence
Garnier merci monsieur le Président
merci au président de l'arcom pour pour
ses propos vous avez rappelé monsieur le
Président plusieurs fois dans votre
intervention la nécessité que nous
partageons tous ici de médias honnêtes
pluralistes indépendant dans un monde où
là aussi vous l'avez rappelé la
désinformation circule parfois plus vite
que l'information elle-même moi je crois
beaucoup au rôle de nos
médias pour aider nos concitoyens à
forger une pensée complexe dans un monde
où on peut regretter que n'est souvent
voie au chapitre que les propos simples
voire parfois simpliste donc dans ce
contexte l'arcom joue pleinement son
rôle pour Canal is ce paysage médiatique
dans un environnement qui est compliqué
au niveau national on le mesure
actuellement avec tous les débats lié à
la loi immigration et aussi bien sûr au
niveau international avec le conflit
israélo-palestinien je crois avoir lu
monsieur le Président que l'arcom avait
été saisi de nombreuses fois depuis le
début de ce conflit
israélo-palestinien
avec un certain nombre de décisions que
vous avez été amené à prendre qui vont
de la mise en garde à la saisie de
rapporteurs indépendant en vue
d'éventuelles sanctions les décisions
que vous prenez vous le mesurez sont à
la
fois commenté repris par les médias
eux-mêmes et peuvent parfois générer des
interrogations des incompréhensions de
la part de nos concitoyens avec
finalement le sujet de savoir ce qui
relève mon collègue Pierre-Antoine
léville a dit à l'instant de la liberté
d'exprimer une opinion qui bien sûr peut
ne pas plaire à tout le monde d'exprimer
une analyse un propos choquant un propos
humoristique ou en tout cas qui se
revendique comme tel donc est-ce que
vous pourriez monsieur le Président nous
redonner ce matin la hiérarchie des
sanctions de l'arcom que l'arcom
peut-être amené à prononcer et aussi
nous éclairer sur les critères qui
président à vos prises de
décision je vais rajouter une question à
la liste de celle déjà posée concernant
le le renouvellement des
autorisations comment prendrez-vous en
compte les sanctions qu'a pu prendre
l'arcom ces dernières années sur des
bénéficiaires des autorisations avec les
les renouvellements ou pas que vous
aurez à procéder dans quelques
mois merci monsieur le Président merci
euh madame la sénatrice et Messieurs les
les sénateurs je vais m'efforcer de
répondre à toutes ces questions je
peut-être commencer
par la dernière les dernières questions
qui m'ont été posées finalement
sur l'équilibre que que
l'autorité doit assurer entre la liberté
de communication et la protection des
publics et la façon dont elle est amenée
à
intervenir quand c'est nécessaire auprès
auprès des
éditeurs
je rappellerai d'abord que le champ dans
lequel on
intervient c'est celui d'une liberté
publique fondamentale qui est celui de
la liberté de de communication de la
liberté d'expression c'est un principe
dans notre pays de nature
constitutionnel vous le savez il est
consubstantiel à notre démocratie
renvoie très directement à l'article 11
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de
1789 l'un des bien le plus précieux de
l'humanité dit cet article et ce droit
cette liberté fondamentale est bien
évidemment extrêmement protégée dans
notre droit il est protégé par la
Constitution il est protégé par nos lois
et il est protégé par nos juridictions
nationales et européenne la loi que nous
mettons en œuvre à
l'arcom il faut toujours le répéter est
d'abord une loi de liberté elle
s'appelle loi relative à la liberté de
communication c'est le pendant pour le
champ audiovisuel de la loi 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse et son article 1
rappelle que la communication est libre
et c'est par exception à ce principe
horizontal fondamental que le
législateur puisque seul le législateur
peut le faire
apposer un certain nombre de limites que
les
éditeurs de programme de télévision ou
de radio sont tenus de respecter donc ce
sont des obligations qui s'imposent à
eux qui sont proposé par la loi ou le
règlement ou par les conventions que
nous sommes amenés à conclure avec eux
au moment de la délivrance des
autorisations ça veut dire que d'abord
l'autorité n'intervient jamais bien
évidemment a priori sur des programmes
de télévision ou de radio c'est une
évidence mais il faut le rappeler ici
l'arcom n'est bien évidemment pas une
autorité de censure elle n'assure pas
une police de la pensée les programmes
sont diffusés et sous leur
responsabilité par les
éditeurs mais ils engagent le cas
échéant leur responsabilité si ces
programmes les contenus qu'il diffusent
sont en infraction avec la loi ou avec
les textes conventionnels ou les recomm
délibération que que l'arcom peut être
amené à
prendre sur chacune des alertes qui nous
est adressé quotidiennement c'est une
chose facile à faire il y a un bouton
sur le site de l'arcom et en en une
minute une minute et demi on peut nous
saisir sur un programme qui qui HETE qui
qui choque pour reprendre votre
expression madame madame la
sénatrice nous conduisons une
instruction approfondie ces séquences
sont revisionnées parce qu'àure des
réseaux sociaux l'expérience montre que
bien souvent nous sommes saisis sur des
morceaux tronqués d'une séquence et dès
que vous la remettez en perspective
elles prennent un sens naturellement
différent donc il faut toujours
reprendre la séquence dans son ensemble
pour s'assurer exactement de ce qui a
été dit ou ou montré nous menons une
analyse juridique très approfondie et je
rappelle qu'on a maintenant 40 ans de
jurisprudence derrière nous puisque la
la régulation audiovisuelle a a grosso
modo 40 ans de d'histoire donc le
Conseil d'État a très très souvent
statué sur les décisions que l'ancien
CSA l'arcom maintenant peut être amené à
prendre et donc notre notre ligne
d'intervention elle est très balisée à
la fois par la loi mais aussi par le
juge puisque toutes nos décisions sont
susceptibles de recours contentieux et
et d'annulation possi par par le Conseil
d'État donc on sait la ligne de crête
qu'on doit tenir c'est une ligne de
crête qui est bien évidemment délicate
c'est la raison pour laquelle toutes nos
décisions sans exception sont des
décisions collégiales donc à chaque
réunion du collège chaque mercredi on
examine un certain nombre de saisines
que nous avons reçu au cours des des
semaines écoulées et cette délibération
débouche donc sur nos positions je
rappelle que dans notre collège euh on a
plusieurs magistrats on a un membre du
Conseil d'État on a magistrat de la Cour
de cassation on a quelques juristes et
mérite au-delà de la compétence très
forte des services en la matière et donc
on est toujours sur cette ligne de crête
est-on dans le champ de la
liberté ce qui justifie que le
régulateur n'intervienne pas ou en tout
cas n'interviennne pas dans une
procédure de de de de de sanction de
nature coercitive ù est-on dans le champ
d'une d'une infraction au regard des
dispositions fixées par la loi nos
outils sont sont simples il y a une
gradation la loi nous impose une
proportionnalité dans nos interventions
la nature des des signalements qui nous
sont faits sont très variables c'est une
chose d'être saisie sur l'utilisation
d'un mot de frananglais par un animateur
qui est prohibé puisque nous sommes
censés défendre la loi la langue
française et nous y veillons c'est autre
chose d'être saisi sur une incitation
explicite à la haine une expression
raciste antisémite un appel à la
violence il y a il y a bien évidemment
une gradation une gradation à avoir dans
nos interventions donc le premier degré
de nos interventions ça peut être une
simple mise en garde donc une alerte
qu'on adresse à l'éditeur en lui disant
attention là bon on n pas constaté en
tant que tel de manquement mais on
estime qu'il faut alerter néanmoins
l'éditeur parce que l'opinion public a
pu être a pu être ému d'un d'un contenu
diffusé l'étape normale de notre
intervention c'est la mise en demeure
dès qu'on constate un manquement la loi
nous impose dans un premier temps de
prononcer une mise en demeure on ne peut
pas sanctionner directement un médiat la
loi impose de prononcer d'abord une mise
en demeure sur un motif
précis et ce n'est que si sur le même
motif précis qui a fait l'objet d'une
mise en demeure il y a réitération du
manquement que nous pouvons rentrer dans
une procédure de sanction qui passe par
un rapporteur indépendant un membre du
Conseil d'État qui on transmet le
dossier qui décide lui-même s'il engage
des
poursuites la liberté c'est lui qui joue
le rôle du procureur si je puis dire qui
instruit ensuite l'affaire de manière
contradictoire avec l'éditeur et au vu
de son rapport le collège de l'arcom est
à ce moment-là saisi convoque l'éditeur
qui est auditionné avec ses conseils et
le cas échéant statut et prononce s'il
le juge utile une sanction la gradation
des sanctions va de la publication d'un
communiqué on peut imposer éditeur de
publier un communiqué dont nous
rédigeons le texte une formule que nous
n'utilisons plus depuis déjà de
nombreuses années une sanction de nature
financière qui est celle que nous
utilisons le plus fréquemment qui peut
aller jusqu'à 4 % du chiffre d'affaires
de la société concerné 5 % en cas de
récidive et la sanction ultime c'est le
retrait de l'autorisation de l'éditeur
qui bien évidemment ne peut se faire que
dans des cas vous l'imaginez très très
graves l'arcom ne l'a fait qu'une fois
sous mon prédécesseur et comme vous le
savez la décision du régulateur a été
annulé par le Conseil
d'État donc donc voilà la gradation de
nos de nos interventions je dis ici très
simplement que l'arcom n'hésite pas
chaque fois qu'un manquement caractérisé
est constaté mais encore faut-il qu'il
soit caractérisé précisément et qu'il a
une assise juridique solide au regard du
droit en vigueur et des jurisprudences
en vigueur la main de LARCOM et de son
collège ne tremble pas on a prononcé
cette année les sanctions les plus
élevées qu'on a prononcé dans toute
l'histoire de la régulation avec une
amende de 3 million et dei d'euros sur
un éditeur un peu plus de 4 % du du
chiffre
d'affaires sous ma présidence on a
sanctionné pour la première fois une
chaîne d'information avec une amende une
amende significative donc le régulateur
n'hésite pas quant un manquement
caractérisé mais encore faut-il qu'il
soit caractérisé j'insiste sur ce point
parce que notre droit une encore est
très protecteur de la liberté il y a un
arrêt topique de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui dit bien les
choses la liberté d'expression c'est
aussi des contenus qui heurtent et qui
choquent c'est ça l'essence de la
liberté d'expression c'est que chacun
exprime un point de vue un point de vue
qui peut nous Horter qui peut nous
choquer mais qui aussi peut faire
évoluer notre analyse et le débat
démocratique vous êtes dans une enceinte
parlementaire votre quotidien c'est bien
ça c'est de vous opposer par des par des
points de vue parfois de façon très très
vive et au bout du compte le consensus
se dégage c'est ça l'essence de la
liberté d'expression et de la démocratie
mais le régulateur je le dis et et
j'insiste là-dessus n'hésite pas à
utiliser les outils qui sont les siens
chaque fois qu'un manquement est
constaté ou caractérisé dans dans le
respect de la liberté et je réponds à
votre question monsieur le
Président le manquement d'un éditeur à
ses
obligations pour un éditeur qui
recandidaterait à ses fréquences un
manquement répété ou réitérer peut-être
naturellement un paramètre que le
régulateur peut-être amené à prendre en
compte ce n'est pas le seul paramètre la
loi indique bien les critères que nous
devons appliquer pour attribuer les
autorisations des mtres pour attribuer
les
fréquences c'est notamment bien
évidemment au premier chef le pluralisme
c'est naturellement au premier chef
l'intérêt du téléspectateur mais le non
respect par un éditeur de ces
obligations est un paramètre que le
régulateur peut peut tout à fait prendre
en compte dans son processus de de de
décision puisque ce thème a été évoqué
sur l'appel à candidature qui vient donc
je B je rappelle que bien évidemment la
décision qu'on prendra sera prise en
toute indépendance en toute
impartialité en toute
collégialité en transparence absolue
toutes les étapes de cette procédure est
sont transparentes consultation publique
je l'ai dit nous allons rendre les les
conclusions la synthèse de cette
consultation publique dans quelques
jours étude d'impact je l'ai dit elle
sera publiée avant la fin de l'année
appel à candidature il interviendra au
début de l'année prochaine je l'ai dit
l'appel à candidature sera publié
audition publique des candidats comme
son n l'indique c'est une audition
publique publication bien évidemment de
la liste des candidats présélectionnés
au terme de l'instruction de leur
dossier de candidature et des auditions
et puis bien évidemment les décisions
d'autorisation et les conventions que
nous sommes amenés à conclure sont
rendus public le
calendrier nous amènera à boucler ce
dossier à à l'automne 2024 avec un appel
à candidature qui sera lancé début
24 remise des dossier le temps
nécessaire aux candidats pour formuler
leur dossier audition publique analyse
des dossiers choix des candidats
attribution négociation des conventions
délivrance des autorisations
signature des des conventions c'est
c'est une étape importante je réponds
puisque la question m'a été posée par
plusieurs d'entre vous C appel à
candidature et l'occasion de repartir
d'une feuille blanche donc les candidats
représentent un dossier l'autorisation
tombe les fréquences sont libérées et
donc on lance un appel à candidature sur
ces 15 fréquences les candidats
présentent des dossiers ils sont libres
de présenter leur dossier ce n'est pas
l'arcom qui fixe un cahier des charges
c'est la liberté de communication qui
prime la liberté éditoriale la liberté
du commerce et deindustrie donc ils
présentent leur dossier nous avons par
contre des critères posés par la loi
pour les choisir au premier chef le
pluralisme et bien évidemment l'intérêt
du spectateur l'équilibre économique du
projet ça va ça va s'en dire euh mais
c'est l'occasion de repartir d'une
feuille blanche et à cette occasion là
nous revoyons les termes des conventions
je réponds très précisément à votre
question donc si vous regardez puisque
nous avons récemment le cas de TF1 et M6
qui nous a beaucoup occupé la convention
de TF1 la convention de M6 a été revue
nous avons agréé tout récemment le
changement de contrôle d'Europe 1 avec
la
commandite dont le gérant est Monsieur
Monsieur Arnaud lagarder donc ça c'est
un changement de contrôle de l'entité
Europe 1 à cette occasion nous avons
revu les termes de la convention sur de
nombreux points pour prendre en compte
l'évolution du paysage pour prendre en
compte l'évolution du cadre législatif
pour prendre en compte aussi ce qu'en
tant que régulateur nous avons été
amenés à observer au cours des au cours
des années des années
écoulées monsieur Brisson sur les
services d'intérêts généraux c'est un
dossier qui est bien évidment très
important qui est très attendu par le
secteur pourquoi parce que je disait
tout à l'heure quand vous achetez une
télévision si cela vous arrive cet
après-midi vous achèterez un téléviseur
généralement fabriqué en
Asie par un constructeur qui a lui-même
conclu des accords avec des fournisseurs
de contenu et quand vous ouvrez votre
écran ben vous verrez apparaître en
priorité des applications qui
correspondent à des services payants
Netflix Amazon Disney peut-être canal
plus mais vous ne verrez pas apparaître
la une la 2 la 3 la 4 la 5 et vos
chaînes de télévision vos chaînes de
télévision favorit vous les retrouverez
bien évidemment mais ça supposera une
petite manipulation sur votre téléviseur
comme je le disais le téléspectateur
moyen est très très jeune mais il est
quand même moins jeune qu'il n'était
autrefois et donc si on prend pas garde
il y a un risque que nos opérateurs
traditionnels soi moins bien exposés que
que que d'autres acteurs d'où cette
notion de service d'intérêts généraux
prévu par une directive européenne qui
est transposée dans le droit dans le
droit français qui permet
d'imposer à ces acteurs une exposition
privilégiée du service public vous
l'avez cité mais aussi d'autres acteurs
loi le dit le dit clairement des acteurs
du notamment du du secteur privé il
revient au régulateur d'arrêter la liste
de ces services d'intérêts généraux et
de fixer les modalités d'accès à ces à
ces
contenus alors il est vrai que cette
évolution du paysage percute les
fournisseurs d'accès percute les les
distributeurs vous avez raison de de le
dire le développement des téléviseurs
connectés fait que le modèle des boxes
est en train d'évoluer c'est un modèle
très présent en France on acccepte
beaucoup à la télévision par
l'intermédiaire des des boxes dans notre
pays mais ce qui est en train de se
développer de plus en plus c'est l'accès
direct via Internet sans passer par la
médiation d'une d'une d'une boxe et donc
le modèle économique des distributeurs
vous avez raison de de le dire est bien
évidemment percuté potentiellement par
cette cette
évolution donc on est bien sûr en
dialogue étroit avec l'arsp hein je
rappelle qu'on a des liens très très
confiants avec cette autorité lorsque
j'ai pris la présidence de de l'arcom on
a signé une convention avec l'ARSEP on a
créé un service commun donc on réunit
régulièrement nos deux nos deux collèges
ensemble et donc c'est des sujets dont
on s'entretient avec avec l'ARS pour
trouver des des points des points
d'équilibre en tout cas la la question
que vous évoquez fait partie de nos de
nos paramètres de de réflexion sur le
DAB+ question qui m'a été posée par par
Madame Robert nous sommes très attentifs
à l'équilibre de notre paysage
audiovisuel on a la chance dans notre
pays d'avoir un paysage extrêmement
dense plus de 1000 radios considérables
des radios nationales des radios locales
des radios publiques des radios privées
des radios associatives des radios
généralistes des radios musicales et
donc cette richesse cette diversité de
notre paysage on est très attentif à le
reproduire sur le Daab et donc les
radios associatives bien évidemment
auront une place au même titre que sur
la bande FM on est très attentif dans
nos décisions dans tous les appels à
candidature qu'on qu'on prononce mais
c'est l'occasion de redire devant vous
l'importance qui s'attache à accompagner
ces acteurs dans cette phase de
déploiement du daab+ et notamment les
associatifs qui supportent effectivement
un coup de double diffusion qui qui qui
est lourd pour ces petites radios qui
nont peu de ressources ell n'ont que peu
accès à la ressource publicitaire du du
fait de l'encadrement juridique qui qui
s'applique à eux le fond de soutien à
l'expression radiophonique prévoit
depuis cette année un petit bonus au
bénéfice de ces radios pour la double
diffusion nous sommes favorables nous le
dirons dans le Livre blanc à ce que cet
accompagnement de l'État qui ne sera pas
de nature à creuser de façon définitive
un déficit déjà considérable des
finances de
l'État soit soit soit
encouragé
sur frch
French Shore c'est un programme en
réalité c'est un format qui est diffusé
déjà depuis 15
ans il est diffusé par des des SMAD
services de médias à la demande il porta
d'autres formats une appellation
différente autrefois s'appelait
gerschor passé plutôt sur l'île sur
l'île de de
Jersey c'est effectivement un service
qui est porté par un service qui est
hors du territoire français qui relève
de la
compétence du du régulateur tchck pour
pour l'un et du régulateur berlinois
pour pour
l'autre nous avons bien évidemment dès
qu'on a été sensibilisé à cette question
nous sommes intervenus j'ai saisi mes
deux homologues des deux pays qui qui
mène une enquête sur les deux services
MTV d'une part et paramon plus d'autre
part
on a eu encore des échanges hier donc
cette instruction est en cours pour
s'assurer du fait qu'il se conforme à la
réglementation telle qu'elle est en
vigueur notamment la la directive
service service médiia audiovisuel le
problème c'est surtout les réseaux
sociaux dans cette affaire là parce que
ce qui a posé problème c'est le fait que
les contenus en en l'espèce qui sont des
contenus interdits interdits au moins de
au moins de 16 ans pour l'un moins 18
ans pour l'autre suivant suivant le pays
concerné le problème c'est que ces
contenus effectivement on été viralisés
sur les réseaux sociaux donc nous sommes
intervenus auprès de ces plateformes
aussi bien TikTok x meta qui ont
eux-mêmes accéléré leur leur modération
de ces de ces contenus mais on est
vraiment typiquement dans dans le cadre
de la régulation des réseaux sociaux
c'est vra vraiment ça ce qui est au cœur
du débat et et donc c'est la question du
déploiement du DSA qui permettra de
mieux répondre à cette à cette
question sur les sites pornographiques
je veux redire ici euh puisque vous
m'interrogez là-dessus que l'arcom n'a
pas ménagé depuis la loi de 2020 et
l'amendement qui a été porté par la
sénatrice Mercier ici euh au titre de la
loi sur les violences conjugales la loi
l'arcom n'a pas ménagé sa peine dès la
mise en œuvre de ce texte de loi je
rappelle que nous avons prononcé des
mises en demeure sur les sites nous
avons saisi le tribunal judiciaire de
Paris pour demander le blocage des
principes auss s que nous avons ciblé et
que nous sommes toujours en attente
d'une décision du juge he 3 ans après
donc l'arcom a rempli son
office voilà donc alors maintenant il y
a un nouveau texte qui est porté par le
par le gouvernement qui pas encore
vootter qui rentrera en vigueur ce texte
prévoit effectivement l'élaboration d'un
référentiel ce référentiel est prêt nous
avons déjà par anticipation sur ce texte
de loi je réponds à votre question
préparer un texte qui est élaboré
conjointement avec laakmil conformément
au texte au texte de la loi et par
rapport au délai de 2 mois quand la loi
sera promulguée nous serons en situation
de le
faire je souligne puisque madame main de
sa qui connaî ces sujets mieux que nous
tous que le récent arrêt de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne et quand
même un coup de tonner dans notre
ciel pour nous tous et y compris pour
les LG ateur nationaux que vous êtes
c'est un c'est un arrêt qui semble
mettre il est en cours d'expertise
d'analyse et on verra exactement
l'application qu'en est faite y compris
pour le projet de loi sren que vous avez
que vous avez évoqué qui semble limiter
les capacités d'intervention d'un État à
l'égard d'acteurs avec des mesures de
portée générale à l'égard d'acteurs
membres qui sont qui sont sur le
territoire de l'Union mais hors de notre
territoire puisque le principe
fondamental du droit de l'Union vous le
savez c'est celui du pays du pays
d'origine ce sujet est en cours
d'expertise mais il est probable je sais
pas quelle est la lecture qui en est
faite par les les services du Sénat les
parlementaires que vous êtes mais il est
probable que le texte du projet de loi
srel devra s'adapter la Commission
européenne a déjà elle-même formulé des
observations à l'égard de la France sur
plusieurs de ces initiatives
législatives en en tout cas c'est un
arrêt à portée extrêmement forte dans
dans dans notre paysage et qui sera à
mon
sens tout de même lourd de conséquences
pour les pour les années pour les années
à
venir l'intelligence artificielle que
vous avez évoqué pour plusieurs d'entre
vous c'est bien évidemment un sujet que
nous regardons de de près d'abord nous
le regardons pour
nous-mêmes on est en train de d'étudier
la manière dont nous pourrions
nous-mêmes utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle dans l'exercice de nos
missions puisque nous avons un certain
nombre de processus qui font appel à des
traitements de données bien évidemment
et et on voit bien
l'utilité que ces outils pourraient
pourrai avoir au service de de la
régulation mais nous regardons
attentivement ce qui se passe pour le
secteur sur deux points qui méritent à
l'évidence attention d'abord la
protection du droits d'auteur
intelligence artificielle travaille avec
des données de masque qui sont pour
beaucoup d'entre elles protégé par le
droit d'auteur comment ce qui est
produit par l'intelligence artificielle
à partir de ces données protège le droit
des auteurs et les droits voisins de de
ces auteurs c'est une question centrale
très complexe mais qui mérite
effectivement une très grande très
grande attention et puis la question de
l'information alors on voit à la fois
bien le progrès que ces outils peut
apporter pour vérifier on parlait
d'ingérance étrangère tout à l'heure
pour vérifier la véracité de certaines
est-ce qu'une image qui est véhiculée a
été produite pour de l'intelligence
artificielle est une fake news une infox
ou pas donc il peut y avoir un côté très
positif dans les outils en même temps on
voit bien
l'aspect les les capacités absolument
phénoménal de création de fausses
informations de manipulation
d'information et et d'ingérence
d'ingérence potentielle donc de ce point
de vuel je je vous réponds monsieur le
sénateur ousulias moi moi je pense que
la régulation européenne est une bonne
étape c'est un c'est un filet minimum je
dirais qui est qui ne brite pas en tant
que tel l'innovation l'innovation
européenne les entreprises
françaises l'expriment pourra se
déployer mais qui assure un filet de
sécurité minimum il sera toujours temps
d'adapter cette cette réglementation à
l'évolution des choses et d'ailleurs de
ce point de vue-là puisqu'on est en fin
de mandat de cette commission européenne
il faut tout de même saluer les
initiatives de cette commission
sur le mandat qui se termine en tout cas
pour le secteur qui nous intéresse entre
la directive service médiia audivisel la
directive droit d'auteur le Règlement
sur les services numériques le DMA le
texte en cours qui sera adopté avant la
fin du présent mandat sur la liberté des
médias en Europe on on nétait pas
habitué à ça pendant de nombreuses
années pour le champ audiovisuel et
culturel la Commission européenne était
l'empêcheur de tourner en rond et on a
enfin l'impression d'une Europe qui
prend conscience qu'elle a des intérêts
à protéger qu'elle a des intérêts à
défendre et que notre exception
culturelle européenne mérite aussi
d'être d'être protégé j'espère que ce
point sera pris en compte dans les
débats à venir pour les échéances pour
les échéances qui nous qui nous
attendent j'ai sûrement oublié des
choses l'audiovisuel
public et la matinale
de
alors l'idée d'avoir une une matinale
n'était pas présenté en tant que tel
dans le dossier de de candidature
de du groupe TF1 tel qu' nous avait été
présenté mais en même temps les dossiers
de candidature présentent une maquette
générale un format général de chaî ne
présente pas une grille minute par
minute de ce qui va se dérouler pendant
les 10 ans de l'autorisation puisque
l'autorisation c'est un engagement que
prend le vis-à-vis de du régulateur il y
a une série d'obligations qui résultent
des engagements qui qui sont pris mais
un ajustement de grille bien évidemment
est toujours possible et tous les
éditeurs modifient leur grille France
Télévision
modifie c'est ces programmes locaux en
ce moment il y a des programmes qui
apparaissent des programmes qui
disparaissent c'est la vie quotidienne
et le changement des grilles n'est pas
soumis en tant que tel à l'approbation
du régulateur ce qui est soumis à notre
contrôle par contre c'est les
obligations du régulateur et s'agissant
de TF1 TF1 a des engagements et des
obligations en matière de programme
jeunesse et notamment des programmes
d'animation dont une partie vous le
savez est diffusée le le matin et donc
le régulateur a fait savoir à TF1 et
nous avons auditionné d'ailleurs TF1 la
semaine dernière que nous serions très
attentif au respect de cette obligation
euh c'est une obligation récente la
convention de TF fin vient signer et
donc le régulateur je je le dis très
nettement sera très vigilant sur le
respect de cette obligation
là voilà maintenant qui est une offre
d'information supplémentaire le matin
participe aussi du du du pluralisme du
débat pluralisme de l'offre dans dans
les médias sur sur le service public bon
je crois que j'ai j'ai répondu
rapidement tout à l'heure donc on attend
les conclusions de cette mission
d'inspection qui devra définir
les objectifs attendus et les
indicateurs permettant de mesurer les
les progrès l'arcom est tout à fait prêt
à être au titre des avis qu'elle rend
tous les ans sur les contrats
d'objectifs à examiner si si les
objectifs attendus les indicateurs sont
sont bien bien remplis encore faut-il
j'insiste là-dessus que les indicateurs
soient suffisamment clairs suffisamment
suffisamment
précis j'ai sûrement oublié quelque
choseapost peutre une question sur
l'expérimentationapost il y a une
question sur le double anonymat
effectivement qui m'a été
posé donc le double anonymat
effectivement il y a des
expérimentations qui sont en cours qui
sont conduites par le par le
gouvernement bon c'est une exigence qui
est posé par la par lail vous savez au
titre de la protection des des
données c'est bien évidemment le
dispositif le le plus sûr c'est de faire
en sorte voilà que qu' une protection
des des données des
personnes il y a d'autres options qui
pourront être envisagées et que le
référentiel auquel on a qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure mentionnera qui est aussi
l'utilisation de la carte bancaire qui
peut être une option possible d'accès
avec une transaction à à 0
€ du moins du moins à court terme en
attendant que le
marché ce qui se produira je je pense
quand même tôt ou tard que le marché
arrive à produire une technologie
permettant de
reconnaître sans avoir accès aux données
de reconnaître l'âge de la personne qui
se qui se connecte donc en tout cas le
notre référentiel fera bien sûr
référence au principe du double anonymat
mais ouvrira l'option au moins de façon
transitoire et à court terme sur euh sur
la sur la carte sur la carte de crédit
madame Mor de merci de votre soutien à
l'appui de nos moyens
euh il faudra aller il faudra aller en
en marchant mais bon c'est mes
successeurs qui viendront plaider leur
cause je pense devant devant le
Parlement en temps et heure on a obtenu
donc des emplois supplémentaires en 2023
en 2024 qui permet de monter en en
puissance de recruter de nouveaux
profils euh on réfléchit aussi à la
modernisation de de nos outils hein je
parl d'intelligence artificielle qui
probablement sur certains métiers peut
nous permettre de dégager des des des
marges de manœuvre pour redéployer nos
nos ressources mais c'est sûr qu'il
faudra qu'on y soit qu'on y soit
attentif dans dans les années qui
viennent puisque nos missions n mission
grâce à vous et nous y voyons un signe
de de votre confiance se sont
considérablement élargis depuis depuis 5
ans pardon d'avoir été un peu long dans
mes réponses non non merci monsieur le
Président de ces réponses très précis
comme vous avez l'habitude de le faire
devant notre commission je crois que
c'est une semaine chargée pour vous en
tout cas du point de vue du dialogue
avec le Parlement souite une bonne
semaine et nous étions heureux de
d'avoir cet échange serein et
constructif comme nous l'avons toujours
eu ici avec vous merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci à vous
tous